and look at the opening bishop b5 check
but okay uh now it's playing
d4 cd knight d4
knight d4 is round no 24 as well yeah
24 is the way to basically to
you can have this door which is very
very
well known and probably yeah
it's a professional door like quincy
incredibly well known
yeah so uh magnus
is a knight on d4 which now looks like
um a night off with bishop b5 checks
this is
really weird stuff for white
bishop is seven played by haddock after
castle he went a6 bishop a for e64 still
very very dangerous to take the pawn
obviously knight f6
we can go maybe night f5 yes
let's say oh even bishop f4 i don't know
whatever
i'm sure radek didn't consider seriously
taking the pawn and he's going bishop
and here the world champion let's have a
look at uh
the number the scandinavian number one
magnus carson
our champion
and he played f4 at b6
so no more knight e5 okay makes sense if
b6 knight c6 actually
that makes a lot of sense knight b6
bishop b3
e5 played knight f5
takes takes
outside
okay is that to be strong it is a bit
strong
yeah for kf8 g4 went ef bishop before
bishop f8 queen g2
and carson much better
yes that's all all of a sudden what was
the blender
i started with rook 8 we wanted takes i
was the same position
according to engine 80
maybe queen c5 d5 i don't know i want h6
but maybe h4 you come anyway the main
game of the day is the world champion as
white
against uh the polish grand master
and he sacrificed the pawn as we saw
he played queen g2 knight takes c4 g5
knight h5
knight d5 queen c5 king h1 this is the
position we are discussing with
jan and
it looks like
very very good compensations of course
even crushing compensations
knight f6 is in the air g6 is in the air
uses knight
on c4 is not really stable you can play
b5 but let's say
if you go b5 seems the most uh
logical to me just to protect the knight
on c4
if i speak bad about uh if i speak good
about marvelous it means really
it's probably just but look safe king
what's not to like well okay some g6
stuff i would be worried you know
you would be worried no yes i mean
it looks positionally it looks really
bad that's that's my main way i don't
care about the attack yeah you don't
like you know being mated you you don't
mind
uh the only problem is uh just being
positionally crushed yeah
yeah that's that's the biggest
humiliation a man can face
okay g6 played by magnus carlsen
uh now playing faster but it
plays by by itself simply aba
oof that's not the move you want to make
but it was difficult to give any clever
advices to
to voita here yeah at the end of the day
magnus the best player in the world and
he made fewer mistakes so far
like so magnus carson decided not to
take on f7 apparently as
winning position according to yeah he
went rook f4
and radik didn't go for this f3 h6
and rook e5 and now
i mean you are not out of the i mean
we all let's no i'm not saying this was
winning you know of course
was playing his first tournament as a
frenchman
and really all games i mean if you
delete the name you think it's uh okay
you think it's
voitersheck just took yeah it took on f5
exactly i wanted to to get back to the
the world champions game okay it's made
what's going on
it's made for sure but how
queen g6 rook d5 yeah there's no mate
here
is that she might win but it's not mate
d5 this is just winning
winning the queen yeah bishop c2 played
by
mr magnus and the computer not a big fan
as far as i could it's going to be fun
okay
here we go again i think okay 7 was a
tequila move but this line we had rook
h7
f36 rook d5 26 looked clean enough no
like
yeah i thought everything bishop c2
queen f2
played by radek
back in business
was that missed let's see if there's any
headshakes
can i can i give a check here what do
you do king f7 yeah
because vocab 7 uh it's not really
um king h8 there's queen f2
which is nice yeah of course what's
wrong with queen f6
yes highly too many pieces huh
yep so quickly f2 could have been missed
by magnus carlsen
radek seems sort of back
magnus looks a bit nervous yeah or are
nervous but looks like something
what can you do here seven minutes clock
is ticking it's move 25
okay
okay that's not
oh we're getting some drama here looked
like magnus was just cruising
exactly to a strategic victory but now
it's
move by move calculation
and it doesn't seem so easy for white
what to do
so king f7
magnus two minutes
that's busy for actually still probably
what's happening after 95 but yeah oh
okay maybe
95 i don't know yeah it's a mess but
white was apparently
better but probably bishop before yeah
i don't have an eight here we shot g6 or
bishop h7 or something
master of course 130 for magnus carlsen
upon taking [ __ ] was the only move not
losing on the spot yes
king james and the players going to
establish no but magnus
normally doesn't offer doors will
also would be strange time to offer
journalists
i'm not sure high pressure if you offer
a draw here
in the voyager x shoes i would feel that
i have better chances now
if there's nothing direct you could take
your chances easier said than done
of course and your line which came
naturally
five that looked it's centralized
yeah centralization as usual
very good move controlling here
keeping eye here and i hear couldn't be
too why not to start pawn after all
yeah that's to me it looks
much more human than queen h6 square h6
your queen is
half topped it's not attacked of course
but uh
yeah what's where are you going next
with your queen
nowhere no it looks passive queen okay
okay
one now let's see if he goes back or if
he centralizes
he will central us yeah he's sometimes
he's playing for a win
he has to do it it's uh it's good math
uh it's not enough to to make two
dollars against
world champion because you still have to
play happiness
yeah no this is his best chance and he's
going for it which
understanding is your best chance is one
thing but to go for it yeah
turn down the draw with black it's
impressive good stuff by zardin
let's see how this goes oof 22
20 and he plays here here he comes boom
queen h3 impressive
very i impressive it look
he missed it it's clear from uh
from his face and he had the
pen on his hand and he didn't hide it
immediately
that was clear uh he didn't consider
that move
properly and he's in a way shocked but
okay
i guess now we'll come down to he has to
take him
or he doesn't have to take it he could
play h6
i i don't really know
knight f6 now if queen f6 bishop p6
3f if gf
i do think i've made but um didn't see
it so far so
simply i go b3 you know it's too much
and he takes he takes 25 rooker free
plate
he played okay he will
feels like they both know it's a trauma
or
taking his time but there's no other
move that's going differently yeah but
why not
yeah i think it's great to come back
anyway
yeah it was completely crushed and
magnus just missed
a small tactical detail because this
could have two
and you can see the tension is
disappearing from magnus he knows
yeah here bishop c2 was a mistake
rokerson was winning he probably saw
that both are winning with your
nice little line okay f2 catch seven of
g2 net f6
takes days yeah i think he could resist
but bad news queen f2 very clever move
you want to exchange queens you want to
take on h4 as well
and yet to find some monsters
uh like the line was taking on f7 here
and queenie form with the idea queen f3
takes takes king g2
but who does that really
and now they are just repeating the
moves
there is no way out
we'll see your handshake other soon
no they are handshaking
you'll see we will see
magnus will say yeah and they are
shaking hands
so disappointing result for magnus
carson of course considering
the pressure yet but i think he might
have dodged a bullet anyway or he
no he didn't dodge bullet but he wheeled
himself back into it because he had to
find some amazing moves
not to be in trouble this queen h3
hanging the knight with check
well now okay it's annoying for him to
have to go play tie breaks but he
remains a favorite
he gets more games getting two pawns
down with
30 seconds per move this was a scary
spot yeah
exactly so we're seeing world number one
tomorrow what champion magnus carson and
we will see
as well another table alexander i think
in the women's section made it she won
the second game
equalized one one and we'll see
tay breaks against antoinette stephanov
that whoa
it's not going to be a simple takeaway
for guys kinah as
stefano likes a very strong um in rapid
and also the experience in this kind of
matches so
that will be as well very interesting
let's see
what's going on in the other games what
we'll see
what champion discussing the games with
adek